Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
If we study the laws of fluid motion from
physics, and write a computer program that
contains these laws, we can create wondrous
fluid simulations like the ones you see here.
The amount of detail we can simulate with
these programs is increasing every year, not
only due to the fact that hardware improves
over time, but also, the pace of progress
in computer graphics research is truly remarkable.
So, it s there nothing else to do?
Are we done with fluid simulation research?
Oh, no.
No, no, no.
For instance, fluid-solid interaction still
remains a challenging phenomenon to simulate.
This means that the sand is allowed to have
an effect on the fluid, but at the same time,
as the fluid sloshes around, it also moves
the sand particles within.
This is what we refer to as two-way coupling.
Note that this previous work that you see
here was built on the Material Point Method,
a hybrid simulation technique that uses both
particles and grids, whereas this new paper
introduces proper fluid-solid coupling to
the simpler, grid-based simulators.
Not only that, but this new work also shows
us that there are different kinds of two-way
coupling.
If we look at this footage with the honey
and the dipper, it looks great, however, this
still doesn’t seem right to me.
We are doing science here, so fortunately,
we don’t need to guess what seems or doesn’t
seem right.
This is my favorite part, because this is
when we let reality be our judge and compare
to what exactly happens in the real world.
So let’s do that!
Whoa!
There is quite a bit of a difference, because
in reality, the honey is able to support the
dipper.
One-way coupling, of course, cannot simulate
this kind of back and forth interaction, and
neither can weak two-way coupling pull this
off.
And now, let’s see, YES!
There we go, the new strong two-way coupling
method finally gets this right.
And not only that, but what I really love
about this is that it also gets small nuances
right.
I will try to speed up the footage a little,
so you can see that the honey doesn’t only
support the dipper, but the dipper still has
some subtle movements both in reality and
in the simulation.
A+.
Love it.
So, what is the problem?
Why is this so difficult to simulate?
One of the key problems here is being able
to have a simulation that has a fine resolution
in the areas where a fluid and a solid intersect
each other.
If we create a super detailed simulation,
it will take from hours to days to compute,
but on the other hand, if we have a too coarse
one, it will compute the required deformations
in so few of these grid points that we’ll
get a really inaccurate simulation, and not
only that, but we will even miss some of the
interactions completely.
This paper proposes a neat new volume estimation
technique that focuses these computations
to where the action happens, and only there,
which means that we can get these really incredible
results, even if we only run a relatively
coarse simulation.
I could watch these gooey, viscous simulations
all day long.
If you have a closer look at the paper in
the description, you will find some hard data
that shows that this technique executes quicker
than other methods that are able to provide
comparable results.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!